trevor rogers gets the ball his 24th
start this year coming off a start
against the nationals where he really
had a tough time putting the nationals
away high pitch count early on the
left-hander is facing a right-handed
batter lane thomas batting 247.
and it's a fastball that gets him rogers
has his first strikeout tonight a base
runner for washington and for josh bell
two balls in a strike on bell who shoots
one out to right field sanchez going
over leaping and he makes the catch
oh
what a week it's been defensively for
jesus sanchez there's josh rogers
five innings a hit no runs in that start
last week against miami here at
nationals park yeah last two starts he's
allowed just two earned runs in 11 and
two thirds endings that's a one five
four era with seven strikeouts and two
walks nationals will bring the infield
in here with one out against brian de la
cruz hitting 321 in 46 games seven
doubles a triple
that is gash de soto runner tagging and
he'll have to go back when you talk
about the improved defense for soto it's
not just the plays he's making it's
where he's standing and the hits he's
taken away in right field
he would have been comfortable enough to
play that shallow last year but he's
getting more confidence he's confident
going back on the baseball so now he's
taking hits away and playing way more
shallow two down big out and rojas at
third for it jesus sanchez swinging a
fly ball left field this is an easy play
for yadiel hernandez and he makes the
one-handed catch
and the marlins out on three fly balls
two on for eddie alvarez switch hitter
he'll be batting right-handed against
the left-hander
up the middle
tag throw
4-3 it appears inning over first and
second with two outs for josh bell their
cleanup hitter bell hit went out to deep
right field his first time up
and a ground ball to jazz
inning over
it took some work miguel rojas doubled
in the first inning
he's up again here in the third inning
mickey right field line a
foul ball oh meggy thought that was fair
he's gonna run to second i don't
[Applause]
look at that well it's been waved as a
dead ball but maybe he's gonna end up in
third
he's trying to play it out it is a
reviewable call as it's down the line
the marlins are going to ask for a
review smart move by mickey to keep
running it's a foul ball and mickey
comes back to the plate
he's drilled another one to left center
but yaddia hernandez over to grab it
ball crushed
and caught by our left fielder two down
and here's jazz chisholm chisholm flied
to deep center moving a runner in the
first inning and a swing and a miss and
he's got it his first strikeout is
chisholm flails on a strikeout rogers
did a little stutter step going off the
mound like he was mimicking the
home run trot of jazz chisholm well that
was a pretty good strikeout trot for
josh rogers
strikeout victim his first time up five
of those so far for rogers
swinging to miss and rogers has
six strikeouts two down
and mercer struck out
in the second inning
got him to chase they apply the tag
mercer's down on strikes and a nice
quick efficient one two three inning
rogers back to work after a couple of
strikeouts in the fourth inning
in and around the zone all night long
that's his eighth strikeout third in a
row one away in the top of the fifth
josh rogers
the pitcher will come up
called strike three that's nine and four
in a row nick fortes he's one for one
rogers rocks and fires
and fortes hits one out to left field
this one's deep and it's gone
a solo home run for nick fortes and the
marlins break through
hell nick continues to impress he is
showed up swinging the bat in miami
another home run two starts two
homers comes back and this is a lead off
walk to escobar
and that brings soto to the plate
and a string of
played appearances without a strikeout
comes to a close for soto and it's
number 10 for rogers
the change up puts him away got him at
43 plate appearances in between
strikeouts which is utterly impressive
yeah
second longest active streak so now
it'll be k barrett ruiz
who drove in four runs last night he's
one for two in this game
and ruiz has another base hit
here comes escobar around third
throws behind him he knocks down the
catcher who is in his way
and then we have a runner at third safe
as belt continues to motor around the
ballpark
fortes
and escobar are down
that's a scary play as the throw kind of
took fortes into the line and escobar
just ran over fortes
both guys now sitting up that is a good
sign it was
very very hard contact and escobar is in
the scores so this game is tied at one
the other way rojas off his glove the
nets take the lead
ruiz stops at second and yada yelled
delivers rbi number 29.
still one out
runners at first and second
mercer has struck out twice tonight
that's two for four
josh rogers have kept the marlins from
doing
risk damage
and that ball was out over the plate
that's headed for the gap in right
center
ruiz coming around heading for third is
yadiel hernandez
mercer's out at second base he knew it
but he just put the nets up by a couple
and sent another runner to third garcia
gets bass for the first time
he got a fastball down the middle rojas
can't handle that
and the gnats have added another run
here's chisholm struck out swinging last
time
just get one out if you can
and he does
tremendous play by josh rogers
against a blindingly fast runner what a
play by josh rogers that had hit written
all over it didn't it
i'm thinking there's no way he makes
this play
and then i was wondering if josh bell's
foot was on the base and it was look at
the mud all over the baseball he hit it
right off the plate a little backhanded
glove flip
and josh bell with the olay at the end
to get the fastest guy in the marlins
team what a play by josh rogers are you
kidding me there's de la cruz
oh look at the pick by escobar
long hop to bell the nets are playing
some baseball tonight look at that oh my
goodness from a knee good pick josh bell
the bases are loaded with marlins
with jesus sanchez coming up sanchez
tonight fly ball to left liner to right
ground ball to second
ground ball right side
garcia to escobar
nancy out of the inning second and third
escobar walked
and scored a run in the sixth inning
in the middle of the plate escobar
is going to increase the nats lead
garcia home
elaine thomas just
screaming around the bases and now it's
six to one and that'll bring up juan
soto
fastball ripped into right
escobar scores
and juan soto has a two for four night
and rbi number 87. it's now washington 7
and miami 1.